Hey,
what's going on is bill,
it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and fucking pissed.
And I'm checking in on you.
God Damn,
Internet's not working.
I can't get,
I,
I swear to God,
you know,
I want to go back to 1995 right before all of the laptops and all of that shit
came in,
didn't have a cell phone,
right?
Just walking around,
you know,
with my dad down to efficient whole,
but up up.
Uh,
but up,
up,
boop,
boop.
Like how long has this casino for?
Like fucking a week.
My phone wasn't ringing.
I couldn't figure it out.
I went on the Internet,
I found,
I looked for all of this shit.
Go into your settings,
click on this,
and I could never find fucking anything.
And I found out I somehow put it on do not disturb,
which involves swiping your screen up somehow.
And I'd have to hit a button and I,
you know what probably happened,
I probably,
I dunno what lifted my leg to tie my shoe while my phone was in my pocket.
And then there's that bullshit for the whole frigging week,
you know,
and the overall scope of global problems.
It's probably not that big before.
I'm sitting
on this spinning marvel that the God and Shit,
when people talk about,
wait,
what am I fucking asshole comes up to me and talks about some space thing that
they watched and how small insignificant the fucking earth is.
One more person tells me that shit.
I get it.
Space is big and we're small.
All right,
so what do you want to do,
Dee Dee Dee
getting kicked in the balls still hurts,
right?
So what's the point anyways?
The lovely Nia is he of Nia pickup on microphone.
All right.
Hey,
how are you?
You and I got into when
I can get it to you today from Amazon.
What?
The bar that you won't let me have,
you won't share with me.
I won't.
And it's an uneasy when you can't share with me.
I'm your wife.
Like why wouldn't you show that you don't share?
You just take,
I asked you if I could through no,
cause this is okay.
This is what happens whenever I go on a diet.
All right.
I start looking like go shredded red face over here.
She's like,
Ooh,
what are you doing?
Oh.
And then she fucking,
rather than getting on the Diet,
she just picks it all this shit that I bought.
And you know when you're on a fucking diet you got it all mapped out for the
week.
So you don't have to think,
you know,
you can't wait until you're hungry cause then your body's going to be like,
go on a cheeseburger.
You're man and you got to do it in the handbag.
It,
no,
what did cheeseburger?
I want a chocolate shake.
You'll have nothing.
Um,
he says how it works for me.
So some meal prep,
I get it.
All right,
so,
which I just have a bar,
like we just came from a walk,
like why can't I have a,
a bar like to refuel to find and it was the last one.
And you just want to have one,
not because you're on the diet because it's convenient.
And then I'm going to come that tomorrow there's going to be an empty box.
So now I got to go online.
You're going to get me that tomorrow today.
Cause it's prime.
Yes.
And how much does that cost?
49 for the box.
But here's the thing,
Nia,
the thing,
if I didn't make such a fucking stink about this,
I don't know why you had to make a distinct period,
but like it's my last one.
Yeah.
And I,
it's hard to find.
Okay,
let me see if I can buy.
Hey,
I can get some for you.
That'll be delivered today.
Can I have one now?
You're telling me that that would have worked?
Yeah,
you're full of shit.
We'll never know because you'll always pop off.
So who knows what'll pop off?
I'm white.
Flip out.
No,
that's plenty.
Thank you.
Every once in a while I do have a good one.
No,
the same thing I've learned about you,
which I then translate to implementing it and I'm pointing right at you,
which I then of course transfer to all fucking women because that's how simple
my brain is,
is you have to make a fucking scene for you guys to finally do the right thing.
That's what it is.
Cause you might cause she,
you aren't just dramatic and like overly,
what's the word I'm looking for?
I Dunno,
overly interrupting me every time I go to make a point.
That's the second time you've done it.
One more time and I'll tell you your Audi and I'm out of the ballgame.
Yeah,
you're going to do that.
Can I know woo woo.
You can stack like this,
a little pound puppy and then I'm going to give it to you and you're going to
say that you're going to fucking do it.
You're going to say that there's going to be followed through like this fucking
autumn and over here that has a stuffing coming out of it and left a message.
He was supposed to take care of that like three fucking months ago.
Okay.
All those little balls are coming out.
We got a kid around here.
I don't want you to start to eat.
I'm thinking that they're,
they're the little things.
A fucking cous cous or something.
But she knows what that is.
So this,
this leaky fucking piece of shit that,
I don't know where you got it from.
West Elm.
So how much was that?
A zillion dollars right now.
It was like 45 bucks or something.
All right.
Well then throw it out.
I don't know what to tell.
You can just leave it leaking all over the place.
All you gotta do just find some fucking no,
cause this is what it is.
And you know,
I have to take care of all of this shit.
That's why you don't get a fucking power bar because she wouldn't have done it.
You would've said you were going to do it and then you wouldn't have done it.
And the amount of time would have taken me to figure out the fucking Internet
and how to get some fucking look at me.
So fucking,
uh,
what a,
this dress.
I'm like,
now I'm going of dress like fucking Hitler.
Youth with the lumberjack must beard and mustache.
Right?
The Conor Mcgregor,
but like Zach Galifianakis.
Okay,
beard.
Who was the originator?
They all owe him money.
He brought them back.
The Martin van Buren beard.
Um,
he's like the Eddie van Halen,
right?
You're throwing out the names of a lot of white guys.
Inhaling up the beard and the loss and all these surfaces that came along where
all those guys that ripped off Eddie van Halen.
Oh,
speaking of that,
the next season of baskets is coming out with Lou.
You had to sit there.
I love that show.
Anyway,
that's why.
That's why you don't get,
you don't get a,
you know what's so funny about Uni,
right?
Is I'm trying to communicate with you and you're on your phone.
I'm on Amazon ordering the Goddamn thing for you,
and I said,
well,
you're not going to happen.
My fucking freckled arbs.
This is what I have to do.
This is why you actually don't.
You actually don't have to have this reaction.
Okay?
Okay,
let's do a little role play.
All right.
I'm going to be you.
Oh,
Wow.
Okay.
And then you can be me and you tell me how to do it.
Oh,
what am I,
where are we talking?
We're talking about what the fuck just happened.
So I'm you and you're okay.
Here we go.
Well,
you have I tonight
I object to this and let me like,
he was just going to be worse.
It's what you like and you have something.
I want something.
I'm a fucking five year old.
Can I hit it?
I have to take care of it three months ago.
Wow.
Fair enough.
I busted my ass on the road every weekend so we can afford this fucking house.
That's a good point.
Are there care was always an unflattering impression.
I agree with you.
A version of me.
Every time you talk like that,
I swear to God,
like part of my soul to Blake's off that I know that's what you do.
Do I have gone why?
By the time it goes into my head,
God with my fucking childhood and all my experiences,
or you need an eye processing.
Oh God.
So it's,
you know,
you've got a guy every excuse in the book while I was popping off and you know
what,
slipping out,
whatever,
whatever.
And it's just like you don't have a point right now.
I just saw that you started that searching for word.
You've got every thing and it's just like,
hey man,
that would be more of this bandage and this Sunday that way saying I need to be
out.
That was three quarters,
three quarters of a fucking point.
You just made that cause you know man,
it's like shit is crazy.
Need to do there and start the the,
the lady fake crying.
I hope you know that your shit is coming today and look what I had to do.
But how high my blood pressure had to go off and didn't have to do all that.
I could have figured it out for you if you were nicer to me if you were like,
you know what?
This is,
it's role play.
Let's role play.
Let's start over again.
And this time rather than insulting each other rather than insulting each other
from the essay that you had,
goddammit.
To supply points.
I'll take your fucking purple sock off right now.
You could have said it's my last one and I,
okay.
The way I would have liked you to do it,
we're going to do this.
We're going to finish this fucking thing.
Okay.
All right.
I'm going to be you.
I want to try to do a flattering version of you.
Okay?
Go ahead.
Can I have
you?
Oh,
it's my son.
Yeah,
I can
see you can't do it.
No Kid.
Uh,
alright.
Do,
what did you tell me?
How?
Tell you tell me.
You tell me.
I wasn't really told me how the fuck I'm supposed to do that.
You weren't supposed to say I only have one lot and they're really hard to find.
And I said,
okay.
So
that's what you would've said.
I would've been like,
well,
let me see if they have any online on Amazon like I did just now.
Like it's literally coming before the end of the day.
Chocolate bar is more important than me.
I'm just saying.
I think your reaction was a little over the top and unwarranted.
It wasn't,
I stayed calm.
I stayed calm and as you said,
can I have a chocolate bar?
What?
I said,
no.
Yeah,
and you can put the thing and you're like,
I can't.
And I said No.
He said,
why?
I go because they're mine.
I'm on this diet.
I kind of said that you okay,
but it's your tone and it's your approach.
You often saying from Massachusetts,
I always sound like I'm in a bad mood now.
Not as not true.
All my family's from Massachusetts and they don't always sound like they're in a
bad mood.
So that's a bullshit excuse my white people from Massachusetts.
So we sound like the right and that's fair.
It's okay to blame a race when we return more hate speech from Nia hill.
We're doing an episode.
We did an episode of crushing.
Yes.
We want to share before anybody asks.
No,
that's not our baby.
Okay.
People have already asked me,
this is how Hollywood works.
Okay.
You can't have a baby on set.
Do you have to have twins?
Because they're only allowed to work in three hour shifts.
Right?
So you need to one,
Z,
two Z EBA and baby B as they call all.
Other than that,
I have that story that I told the time I did that acting Gig when I was working
with the baby and one baby was catatonic and the other one was flipping out.
We'll say one's name was Bob,
the other was bill.
Bill was catatonic.
Right.
So we use him for three frigging hours during rehearsal.
Now we're going to switch to the,
but the maniac won't
stop crying.
So the guy switches the names right in front of me and starts calling the baby
Phil who already worked,
starts calling him Bob.
Nothing weeks of me.
And now it's like I'm driving the getaway car.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
So of course by the time we live,
audience gets loaded in the old catatonic is six hours id.
Yeah,
he needs,
he needs a drink.
Can feel that.
Yeah.
So the fucking thing was crying his ass off and right before I walked through
the fake door to do the scene,
he took like a giant yellow like sugar corn pop and with his thumb pushed it to
things mouth and I walked out and I walked up.
They was like
spit it out.
Yeah.
Okay.
If I was a feminist that would have been enough to make me quit the business.
Ho,
Ho Ho Ho.
You know what BV Tom's.
The homes are bullshit Hashtag me too.
Um,
but yes,
we did an episode of crashing airs this Sunday.
I'm very excited to see it.
Um,
yeah.
Yeah.
Wait,
promotion.
This is me for money
and it's entertaining.
I was actually one of the most fun acting gigs I've had.
I took great acting gigs last year.
Right.
You're,
you're,
I'm really,
exactly.
Obviously you're in it more than I am.
Like wow,
we're both self involved.
So you're really excited about your scenes.
I seen they got it done.
They cut two of my three seasons down or you'll be on the DVD.
Is that how it works?
Laser disk or something.
I know now.
Well anyway,
Pete Holmes was kind enough to give me the heads up that they were seeing that
they had to cut for time purposes.
And I understood even though they were really,
really,
really great scenes between me and Pete and then me and Pete and one other
person.
This isn't the way you promote a show.
You talk about what's there.
Yeah.
Well what's,
there is a fabulous as well.
Chaises and I can't wait.
What are you behaving about this?
You tell me you would've,
we would've ordered these fucking chocolate bars unless like flipped out.
I would have helped you if you had asked in the polite way.
That's my philosophy arguments sentence at the end of it was young man.
If you would ask me in a polite way.
Young man.
No,
I'm excited for,
uh,
for,
for crashing.
Shout out to Pete Holmes,
Greg Fitzsimmons
and uh,
the always loved Snelling who was there on set,
but a Judd Apatow.
Absolutely.
Ah,
the director's name.
I can't remember cause I'm a jerk.
But he was so nice and they just made me feel so comfortable and it was great.
It was really fun show which works guys.
Check it out man.
Tweet me about it man.
It's going to be on this Sunday.
It was fun already lags in it.
Uh,
Joe Bay.
Maybe.
Am I supposed to say all this shit but it's uh,
it was fun.
[inaudible] Lord.
I know,
I know.
I'm really see various joy.
Joy was fucking hilarious.
Um,
I'm excited to see that scene that you're talking about.
no,
it felt like we were doing like a talk show.
Yeah,
it was great.
that's the thing.
They really let you kind of Improv and just kind of feel your way through the
scenes with guidelines of course.
But I appreciate that,
you know,
cause it just gives you a chance to have a little creative freedom.
What I wish that you would do some Improv and get that that frigging autumn and
like resewed can we just can,
you can't be telling me out here.
Like you can't find someone in the valley.
It's all we do are of course all upholstery.
It's upholstery in porn.
Tired.
Valid.
It's a couple of smart people value the idea again,
see what industry is born.
Oh street doesn't your only option.
Car Washes were places.
I love the valley may too.
I like,
I like it.
I like it a lot.
So what are we doing here?
It's Thursday.
Like what's happening?
What are we talking about?
What's going on?
It's going on a worldwide.
I don't know what's going on the world cause I don't have,
I don't have the fucking internet anymore and I don't know what channel the news
channels are cause I don't watch them.
Ooh,
I don't,
why aren't you just a rebel?
I'm not a rebel.
I'm uninformed.
I didn't mean like how'd that podcast with Joe de Rosa and so I did not inform
no reading,
no research,
just strong opinions.
I do remember the early days of podcasting.
Was that a podcast?
It's not a podcast and I had already been doing my podcast.
Have you talked about how you first started doing podcasting?
Like,
what does that story,
did someone say,
hey,
hey there young man,
you know,
the needle or one of my retiring and this,
this,
this is the last phrase.
It's called podcasts.
Like what's that blog?
Yes.
No,
I've told the story of Bobby Kelly.
I was like,
hey mister,
how was it?
I was over his,
uh,
apartment anyway,
and I was like,
what's a project?
Because it's
all right.
You called the number,
you called some little hotlines,
Samsung Gig.
You know what's funny is Bob doesn't even remotely talk like that,
but the impression I got more and more exact layer.
PUCCI did it first.
Who was Larry wrote,
g Larry when Pooch Pooch Gucci.
Great Comedian,
Boston guy.
And he was just,
he just would kind of be like,
Hey Mary,
can you kind of,
I don't even know how to do it,
but he,
he,
it was great and impression.
So then we did an impression of his impression and then it just kept getting
more and more exaggerated.
Yeah.
He sounds nothing like that,
but it's fun.
It's fun.
You walk into the room and everybody just goes,
alright,
but you used to call a phone number.
I'd call in and I would drive around.
I'd be in the airport and I make fun of fat people and all this stuff you used
to be able to do before everybody got all sensitive.
Say you call and you can still kick a ginger but you can't make fun of a fatty
when we return,
but it wouldn't be like at the tone,
please leave your broadcasts.
I forget how you did it.
You called up the number and then you punched in your code.
I mean they exist somewhere.
I used to have that picture on my podcast page me with my flip phone,
which was,
oh so cool.
Flip phone was the shit.
2006 Simon,
one of the first iPhone came out and Jim Norton and Bobby,
they all got them and they fucking hated them.
Like everything on it was amazing except the phone part Ram and then they,
then they made the unholy matrimony with Verizon and then they just,
they took over everything.
Like sprint was a viable option back then.
And with that.
Yeah.
I mean,
people still have sprint.
He's talking about look at these fucking Internet in nothing.
Had nothing.
I'm going to sit here all fucking day.
Wait for this to stupid fucking thing to load.
Then I got to have some nerd come over here.
You know what I miss?
I miss the Geek squad before best buy bought it and ruined it and act like they
was still the geek squad.
It's like no your best buy,
right?
Yeah.
I know that
we can reset the um,
the router.
It'd be like,
yeah.
Does that make it work?
I guess?
Yes.
You hit the Brian and I literally have to go into your room.
I have to hit pause.
I have to walk into the other room so this fucking page will load.
Hang on.
All right,
I'm back.
Uh,
Internet just not working at all on the house.
Just be,
they won't be able to upload the fucking podcast.
So I don't know when that was going to come out.
Uh,
finally gone to Google News on my,
on my phone.
Yeah.
There you go.
Who needs a laptop when you got a phone.
All right,
Google cancels,
$30 million,
civilian moon mission price.
They're going to just send some regular person to the fucking moon.
I would have donated to that sense of jerk off up there and watch them freak out
again.
You want to space and all you're going to be on this podcast.
He said,
yes,
I will.
Look at your phone.
What he you don't?
He's still ordering chocolate bars over there flailing the,
I don't have the Internet.
It's like somebody shut off my lights
so I have a question.
Just see any good movies lately now?
Yes.
Ladybird I started watching that and I fell asleep.
It get out.
Doesn't win every single fucking Oscar that they've been nominated for like I'm
done.
Why can't every single every single fucking Oscar?
Well everyone that it's been nominated for it.
Yeah,
I mean my mom think you've slightly biased.
It should definitely,
you should definitely want directive without a doubt.
And I think that kid should win.
Right,
and then what else?
Costumes.
No,
let's,
every single Oscar and I'm talking about everything.
Yeah,
this is a slippery slope.
I'm start talking about a war.
Everyone that they were nominated for,
I can't tell you something you which by the way,
I did all the categories that I predicted that they would be nominated for him.
Oh,
you did?
So I'm glad I was.
So you see things?
Yeah.
Okay.
I see things and see,
even with Google dangling millions of dollars in prize money.
It was a moonshot.
No one could land to get it.
Oh Jesus.
I don't think people in this effort in the press get away with these pumps.
There was a moonshot pause.
No one could land more than a decade.
Would you get off the Internet?
I need your comedic brain here.
Oh,
sorry.
Oh yeah.
I was going through my Twitter to look at news and I thought might be
interesting to throw into the
fucking worst liar ever more than a decade after Google announced it would ward
$30 million to the first company that could launch to the moon by March,
2018 the company has officially canceled the prize.
Who the fuck would waste their time doing that?
You can give me $30 million to special fucking $1 billion to get somebody to the
moon.
I'll give you 20 bucks if you build me a house.
Thanks to me to the moon.
The reason none of the five finalists,
we're on track to meet the fast approach.
we're on track to meet the fast approaching deadlines.
A while.
While we did expect a widow by doubt due to the difficulties of fundraising,
technical and regulatory challenges,
the grant,
but nobody gives a shit.
Wait a minute.
Is this what you do on their sayings?
He just like read news stories or
no,
you'd be like Rehab.
I you see read advertising.
I usually have spells Asia had the internet and I have stuff that I can look at
to start to talk about and riff on.
Why don't you look at your,
uh,
none of that isn't an ed at the little momentum.
I just had.
You just literally stepped on.
I'm sorry.
Keep going.
Yeah.
There was so many.
There was so many angles you could have gone.
This is some white shit.
You ain't ever going to,
you never get to see black astronaut,
you know,
fucking def jam shit.
I don't personally,
white table likely after got out of the mode.
Do you want to go to the moon?
Like would you ever want to go to space?
That's so many.
I don't want to go to the beach.
I'm terrified of the beach.
I would never want to go into space ever.
Ever in my life.
I never want to leave this.
No,
because I'm afraid of being alive.
I don't want to burn it,
but it's such,
I know like safe or whatever now,
but I'm just not,
I dunno.
I was traumatized by the challenge.
Like I'm done.
I'm like,
wait,
where did you read that?
It's safe now.
I Dunno.
So people go up there all the time,
you know,
I don't want to have,
I don't want to have a Sandra Bullock,
you know,
in outer space situation,
like all alone,
you know,
George Clooney's voice and then he's not there anymore,
you know?
And he was content to just float off into space.
Nonchalant.
He was,
he was so nonchalant about it.
He was just like,
hey man.
Oh yeah,
hey,
is that the Serengeti?
He's like,
I don't have anything going on down there,
but you do.
You do man,
and I need you to fight.
Oh,
see,
let me just sort of,
let's go.
Like,
dude,
if you have a floating off into space like that,
you'd be like
making one hero noise.
Right?
So I'm,
I'm definitely afraid of space.
I think it's amazing,
but I have no interest in going in.
Is that,
what was that thing you don't do?
The Med guy did the red bull jump,
you know what?
He was basically jumping from space.
Do you know if the shield is one of his little face mass there?
If that broke his face would melt off within two seconds to saliva in his mouth
would have reached boiling point.
Oh my God.
Is that true?
Yes.
I Dunno.
I read it.
I don't know why anyone would go to space.
I don't know how to talk to women,
but I appreciate those who do they need a good story to space?
No.
All those scientists and astronauts and things,
they're doing good work up there,
but I'm not interested in doing it.
And yet you have no idea what they're doing.
Just you're speaking and fucking,
is it a hyperbole?
Is that they're up there.
They're doing good work.
Yeah.
Talk about some of the good work the astronauts are doing up there.
You know that they're researching that state
running spirit
or I don't want to be like Sam Rockwell's character and mood does it all by
herself going crazy.
Like,
and that was a fucking grant movie was amazing.
Shout out to Sam Rockwell getting nominated for an Oscar.
Yay.
Yeah,
this her family.
I love when he was sitting there and that one scene where he just looks over,
he goes,
who's that guy?
Yeah.
That's probably,
I don't want to ruin it.
I didn't want to,
yeah.
Do you get,
you got to see movie.
If you haven't seen the moon,
you know all you people lined up to six star.
Once you,
if you're making a major error,
I want to go see moon.
They can see.
But yeah,
I dunno why I shouldn't state,
you know why it's just,
it's fun to do.
It's,
I trashed feminists because anything that's like take it so seriously.
You have to shit on a lie.
You have a classic comedian brain.
You can't just like be nice about something like good for them and then standing
up for what they believe and I think that's great.
You just have to shit on it like you and positivity or just like something that
a lot,
I don't know.
I don't get to take it all the way to his positivity.
You guys just don't Mesh.
Like you just refuse to allow positivity into your life.
You're just don't think it's funny and oh it's just you have to break the
tension of somebody telling us storage what sedges someone sharing their story
of why is it tense for you?
You just can't deal if the attention is not on you so you have to turn it around
and make a joke and like make fun with everything up until then.
Okay attention on me when I'm on stage off stage,
I'm not a fucking lampshade on my head Guy am I?
No,
you're not.
Don't try to take over fucking conversations at parties.
I usually am standing at the wall and you're like,
if everything okay are you're having a good time,
the arresting bitch face.
And I'm like,
you do have resting bitch face bow.
It's handsome but it's a bitchy.
I know I'm not good at parties.
Did he like the dance?
I'm like,
I don't know.
Like Ooh,
heightened energy.
I am energy bothers you.
Yeah.
Know
celebratory vibes.
Relaxed people getting along.
No,
not relaxed.
Not relaxed.
It's like the heightened,
like when people say
doing that or when they're clapping applauding somebody who's saying what they
did was brave and there was no guns involved.
There was no life or death situation.
But you know,
it's just sort of your only definition of bravery.
Yeah.
Like I think it has to be like,
you know,
they used to be a good for you slap on the back.
That is now brave.
Hey,
this kid,
I,
he fucking,
you know,
he punched me in the face.
I punched him back.
Oh good for you.
Now it's all that was so brave.
The way you stuck up to that bullied no window.
No.
Well,
what happened now as he gets punched in the face and then he makes a video that
goes viral about that,
but you know,
I've been,
the bully makes one and cries and then they delve into that fucking thing.
And meanwhile there's a swirl of trash two miles deep.
Twice,
two and a half times the size of fucking Texas out there,
out in the Pacific Ocean number,
the first tooth brush you have a fucking used.
It's in there swirling around.
Did you see that story about,
I forgot where this fish was.
Costa Rica maybe,
but they caught a fish.
Um,
you know,
they were fishing and I guess this guy saw one fish and he thought it looks sick
and just weird.
So he cut it open and there was all this garbage and sign of the fish.
Yeah,
I was pretty depressing.
It's horrifying.
And everybody's walking around calling everybody I like and enjoy life
and bill here to let you know
what.
That's my face.
I want to bring you back down to earth cause that's what I do.
Build Bird Truth Speaker about what?
Osei or killer killer life.
Ruiner Jesus Christ.
Do you really think I'm that bad?
Huh?
You and your dark
get my rainbow.
No,
I'm just kidding,
Lord.
Yeah.
I don't know Nigga.
How the fuck can you see something like that and then watch some fucking act of
being called brave because they didn't wear makeup in a movie.
Yeah,
no,
of course.
The perspective is like,
yeah,
we're all going to wear all black tonight and like nobody thinks about,
hey,
who sold that shit together?
There's some fucking little kid and like El Salvador,
he was all blacks.
Right?
Let's fucking beaten him with the other yard
and everybody's Oh,
high five and about what great people they are.
Wow.
It's just funny.
That's all I'm doing here.
Okay.
That's all it is.
I look at TV and I shit on everything that I see.
It makes me laugh.
That's how I do it.
I bet.
Probably dysfunctional.
I've been doing really well this year.
You've watched reality TV and I don't shit on it.
Right.
I just sit there oddly quiet and I feel you looking out of the corner of your
eye.
Like why isn't he saying anything?
Well,
I appreciate you being able to let me enjoy my life and peace.
I know it's hard for you,
but uh,
cause nothing is more important than the lap.
Um,
you're really just feeling yourself right now.
I'm on,
now I'm awake now I'm going to,
okay,
let's do two more hours.
Why can't I have to get the fuck out of here?
But I also,
I have to go for it.
Yeah,
no,
this is one of these classic things with I was younger,
I would bring up all the shit that you do and what it's like to live with you.
But I am,
I am an older,
wiser man and I know that there,
there is no fucking real estate to be gained in that.
So I'm just going to sit here in the pocket and just be like,
okay.
Yeah,
I am the Gospel to live with.
I have a question.
Would you like to go to Paris again?
He spoiled Brat.
Um,
why don't I get it?
Is that a headphones?
How come you're the only one that gets 10 phones?
Aspire has 99% of the time.
I fucking do it by myself.
You have head phones.
You could go out and buy a little Jackie could fucking plug it in and you'd be
fine.
Plug it in,
plug it in.
Okay.
How many times I've gone on somebody else's podcast?
I didn't get headphones.
I never went like,
why do you have stuff?
Do you want these headphones?
You could order some more headphones.
It'll get here in time with the chocolate bars now.
That's okay.
I'm fine.
Thanks.
All right.
This has been bill getting trashed by his lovely wife.
No,
it's great.
You enjoy it then.
I did look at peanut.
Huh?
Why?
I like to say that I was a good sport about it just because it was the
microphones and rotten.
But in about three seconds
he says it'd be shut off if you'd think I was a tyrant tyrant before I'm
supposed to reach some sort of advertising.
I don't have it,
so I guess these people will live.
So me doing it on my cell phone at some point.
All right.
That's it.
Enjoy your weekend.
You conch and uh,
I'll check in on your,
on Monday please watch this week's episode of a crashing on Hbo.
Yup.
And anyways,
all of that stuff.
It's going to be on a Sunday night on HBO and I'm sure it'll be streaming
everybody's streams now and I can check it out then.
Please check it out.
I had such a great time and it was so much fun,
you know,
get to act with you again.
Yeah.
Awesome.
That was good.
As a nice positive experience.
Yeah,
it was.
It was,
it was,
wasn't it?
I was in the middle of it.
Yes.
It's very positive.
What was the other,
the first time we ever acted together?
Oh my gosh.
I remember this.
A failed pilot.
Your pilot?
Yeah,
the bill burr projects,
the untitled bill,
whatever it was,
but we had a whole huge negative cause I thought about the first time you worked
together and I was like,
I don't want to bring it up because it didn't work.
Oh,
but know,
okay,
well all right.
But it was so nice.
Sweater.
A nice time together.
All right.
That's it.
Uh,
I'm going to do a little pop included me creatively.
If you start crying,
I swear to God and I appreciate that.
I really do.
I love you for that.
I love you for having me on.
I said,
shut up.
This isn't,
this isn't this kind of a podcast.
I'm making a moment.
Let me have it.
Thank you so much for including me on your podcast and all your creative
endeavor is all these years.
I love you so much for that.
Very nice.
But you did it whales.
And I just feel like it's a way that you show me that you love me and I
appreciate that.
That's how I keep you from bitching at me.
That does.
He can't play gate me in that way,
but I really do a pretty good,
you take like an arrogant till today.
You were just like talking all kinds of shit.
All right.
Got My mojo going from that walk.
All right,
positive and negative.
I'm going to have a sardine bar after this because there's more coming later
today.
No,
it's funny.
You're going to bite into that routine.
Food can flux.
That's what you're going to do it does it suck?
Yeah,
of course it does.
Healthy.
Um,
but it doesn't like,
I don't know,
have at least a little bit of good flavor to it and just imagine your chocolate
covered sand.
Oh No.
That's what it tastes like.
Okay.
Like the amount of water that you need to drink or like a half of it will be
stuck in your teeth.
Oh,
gross.
It's disgusting.
But she wanted one.
Can I still have it?
Huh?
Can I still have that last one?
This is all like to some insecurity about whether I still love you or not.
Are you willing to give up what you eat will be the last why you are just you
like the way you say no,
like snow to me it's just like I just don't understand.
Well what are you look fucking princess.
I'm your wife.
So I should be hearing yes,
like most of the time based on what?
Based on my position,
which is what?
As the wave.
And what is your definition of this household?
What is your definition of a wife?
What do you mean?
What does which stammering and what your idea.
What does that mean?
Cause I'm your wife.
I feel like I should have top priority like I should be like,
yeah,
so the gas of course,
whatever you need and our wands you may have.
Do you think that that's like a,
is that a two way street?
Yes.
So full of Shit.
You are such
a spoiled Brat.
That's my whole God damn fall.
But created a fucking monster.
You sound like my dad.
It's like,
you know your dad and I bond a lot about what?
A small boy,
this boy,
he's a spoiled.
You are.
So you guys want to like give me all these wonderful things which I am grateful
for and then you want to call me spoiled like that's not,
that's not fair.
It isn't yet.
We don't want to give you all those six.
We want to shut you up.
I feel like a little five year old I got on this because you love me,
but hey,
go eat your chocolate bar near.
Can I have that?
Yeah,
you could have the whole fucking empty box when you're done.
Put it on your head and walk around like the queen that you are.
All right,
go fuck yourself.
I'll talk to you.
See you guys later.
All right,
here's the advertising sun basket.
my health seeking friends.
I healthy seeking friends.
Two days of not following through with resolutions out.
Oh because the days of sun basket are just beginning,
which means you're going to keep your resolution this year because sun basket
makes it easier than Avma and today you can get $35 off your first order.
When you go to sun basket.com/berbee you are when you have healthy meals
regularly delivered to your door with son.
Buck basket is easy to stay on track.
I'm talking ingredients like organic produce,
responsible,
responsibly raised meats.
Now peg,
don't stay up past your bedtime.
Sorry.
Sustainably sourced fish show BGH organic pasture raised eggs and organic non
GMO TOEFL
that Gmos were only in food.
Oh and house made sauces you can't find anywhere else and it's all personalized.
Sun Basket lets you mix and match from Paleo,
lean and clean,
gluten free,
Vegan,
vegetarian,
Mediterranean and more.
Whatever diet you're on.
I wonder if you want to like the heart attack died if they'd send you like ice
cream,
marinated pork chops and some shit.
I'm trying to kill myself and I'm using your company.
You got the credit card.
Not to mention tons of variety with 18 recipes to choose from each week.
Best of all,
delicious,
easy recipe festival.
Each delicious easy recipe is ready in about 30 minutes.
Just like that woman there.
I remember,
I'm so and so and I make 30 minute meals,
uh,
with sun basket.
You have total flexibility that you can cancel anytime.
Skip anytime and you can choose any meal plan you want.
Go to sun basket.com/ [inaudible] to learn more and get $35 off your first
order.
That sun,
basket.com/burr for all for $35 off sun basket.com/birds that guy next door ever
going to repair whatever it was.
Fucking,
I swear to God,
I don't know what the guys working on in his backyard,
he,
he's been fucking working on it forever.
Total do it yourself job.
Just hire a goddamn pro.
All right,
he looks everybody.
Hell.
There are tons of online mattress retailers popping up these days.
All with one size fits all solutions to a better sleep.
Well,
guess what?
One size fits all doesn't work.
It didn't work with condoms and it doesn't work with mattresses.
He likes sleep offers something that doesn't exist anywhere else.
A mattress personalized to your unique preferences.
I thought it was a performance and sleeping in a sleeping style that won't set
you back.
Thousands of dollars.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr take those simple two to three minutes
sleep quiz.
They'll build a custom mattress.
That will be the best thing you've ever slept on a for couples.
They've even personalize each side of the mattress.
Everyone from Gq to cosmopolitan to New York Times.
They're all talking about how he looks talking about Helix.
And once you try it out,
you'll know why your custom mattress arrives direct to your door in a week.
And shipping is completely free.
Try It for 100 nights would be,
don't love it.
They'll pick it up,
brows and refund you in full.
Throw to a Heloc,
sleep.com/bird right now and you'd get $50 towards your custom mattress sets.
He likes sleep.com/burp at $50 off your order.
Hey,
he looks sleek.com/birth
hey,
what's going on?
It's Belper and this is the,
uh,
Monday morning podcast for a Monday.
The fuck is today's date.
He think I'd,
I never have it ready for Monday,
January 25th,
2010 can you hear that echo?
Uh,
I'm in my old apartment in New York City and uh,
cause I'm back here cause I'm doing some shit and it's a raining to beat the
band.
And a,
actually this week we're going to have a very special guest who is actually over
in the corner right now drying out his,
his pants on the fan,
his grant goodies eight is enough pants.
Uninformed.
Oh,
Mr Joe to rosa making his way over to the couch.
Very special guests,
which we had a studio audience so they could have clapped when you came in to
sit down,
it would've sounded exactly the same if there was an audience here.
Oh Gel bringing the sunshine on a rainy day.
Dead Silence.
How are you man?
It's been a long time.
We haven't done an uninformed for a while and we were going to do one this week,
but we can't,
which is because,
because we're shooting the movie.
Yeah.
You know,
you've made like three kickoffs.
Number four annoying sounds already.
What are they?
Come on here and get kicked around today.
Not to get kicked around you.
Yeah.
My way of saying that I'm fond of you.
Uh,
I noticed by the way,
you're not using your user won't wind sock on the mic.
You switched over to a black wind sock.
You usually have that right blue one.
Well,
you know what happened was I,
uh,
Mike Dog chewed up the orange one was the orange one that I had and then you
know something,
well,
I use the blue one.
Everybody ended up having the orange one.
I went on a couple other people's podcasts.
Jimmy Dore had the orange one.
Everyone had the orange one.
And I thought I was all fucking hip and cool.
Like,
like they didn't make 9 million of them and put them out in every guitar center
around there and not know.
I thought I had the original,
like I went on Ebay but a vintage windscreen.
I didn't,
that's a bummer.
It's a bummer.
Yes,
it is.
Joe.
Joe,
let's tell our raw already.
You know,
you and I are,
have,
uh,
very,
similar attitudes towards people.
What we're big into charities
helping out others.
Yup.
Um,
I went over to a,
decided I was gonna eat healthy.
All right Joe.
So I go over to the,
uh,
the little market over there that will remain nameless so you can keep your
anonymous life here.
Thank you.
You pick level of celebrity.
I walked in there right in this,
this,
you know,
I'm trying to find some milk.
So I'm sitting there looking,
they had like strawberry flavored blueberry flavor.
I'm like,
so I asked the guy that works there.
dude,
what?
Uh,
where's,
where's the regular [inaudible] led to my friend.
I'm like,
where is the regular,
the regular milk?
And he goes,
this is not to know this is all yogurt.
But it was in these big milk,
like,
like court sort of,
uh,
I've never seen yoga in there.
And he goes,
this is all yogurt.
And then just this big exaggerated suite to the other side of the owl.
The milk is over here.
Yeah.
So then I just paused and I looked at him.
I go,
oh right.
That's all I was asking you.
And then he breaks into this big smile.
Oh,
okay.
My friend.
I didn't know.
Fuck you.
You passive aggressive.
Kentucky hates your fucking job and you think just because I don't fucking work
here,
I don't have the Goddamn store memorized.
And you're standing in the aisle with your,
I work here fucking apron.
Yeah.
I'm going to ask you a question where this shit is.
You don't like it.
You quit your fucking job.
I don't want to get either how he acts like it's,
he acts like it's normal that every store sells flavored drinkable yogurt.
That's a product you see everywhere.
It looked like a court.
It was like,
but it was shaped like sort of a bottom heavy broad with no tits shape.
Like
you know what I mean?
Now he's acting like,
well obviously one of those gymnast.
Gotcha.
A Cup chick who rides a bike too much.
I know what you're talking about.
You know I've seen it bill,
cause I'm a cultured man who seemed drinkable yogurt.
But you know,
I wouldn't blame a guy.
They have drinkable yogurt.
That's what that shit was.
When did that come up?
I Dunno,
a couple of years ago.
I don't know when it came out.
I mean,
I knew it existed though.
He was like a game show host with that.
The men is over here.
Like this big sparkly curtain was gonna fucking what a dickhead.
Exactly.
You know what?
I'm glad he fucking stocks the milk shelves.
You know the yogurts show y'all get shit.
No,
he didn't.
He was actually over by the eggs cock sucker.
Yeah,
I was in the right area.
You had guide did that to me today.
I had to call the guy and ask him for information and he goes,
well,
this was all in the email that I'd sent you.
It's just like that.
And I go,
passive aggressive.
I can't call you a moron.
And then I was like,
I'm sorry.
I must have missed that.
I didn't,
I didn't see it.
I apologize.
And he goes,
uh,
he goes,
oh,
well no worries.
I need to do this for you anyway.
So it's not really a big deal.
It's like,
well,
if you needed to do it for me anyway,
shut the fuck up.
If you needed to do,
why do you got to get you a little jab in if you needed to do this for me anyway
to begin with.
Okay,
let's be honest here.
We're both a couple of morons in both those situations.
I wasn't reading the label.
Both of them have jobs and they want to say,
why don't you read the label?
You'd dumb cunt.
Why don't you read your email?
But they can't.
So they have to go passive aggressive.
Well that's what you get.
You're in the service industry.
I am not serve me.
Sorry.
You just have zero tolerance Joe.
He's had zero tolerance.
I'm actually,
you're probably wondering Cibele why you on the road on a Monday beginning,
you usually come back from my,
my,
my stalker.
So listen to this fucking thing every week as I basically,
uh,
I was just thinking,
you know,
I'm basically documenting my life,
one week at a time.
Like if I imagined,
if I just kept doing this,
it's like that and Michael Keaton movie where he's dying.
He was videotaping everything.
What'd he say?
My podcast is like an awful movie that no one can remember.
I liked that movie.
It's called my life.
It's very sad.
Very Sad.
Actually.
I learned about young Joe to Roseanne.
And for those of you going,
who the fuck is Joe to Rosa?
Um,
that's a normal question.
Who Need Care would ask that question?
People who don't watch a comics unleashed this before.
What else have you been on?
I had a Gotham comedy.
I had my premium blend.
I had a presents half hour presents.
Ooh,
the Nacelle shows Iraq,
Iraq.
Uh,
I had been on Carson daily several times.
Several.
It's a regular performer,
uh,
New York City for Christ sakes.
Goddamn regular.
Oh,
that's right.
I forgot I moved away and you took my slot.
They never even miss me.
I was,
that's when I realized when I went to La and just how fucking unbelievably
replaceable I am.
Not that they got somebody else,
but that they replaced me with you,
Joe,
or what I learned,
but I learned was all I had to do was go in and start trashing the guy that was
there before me,
which was you.
And they immediately would stab you in the back and laugh.
Well,
that's what that whole show is about.
Just evil.
As long as I brought a little evil and it didn't give a shit if they're good
guys,
that's what's the greatest part of that show.
He smile at your friend is you see the bus coming up behind them and at the last
second you step out of the way without warning them.
Just watch them get run over.
But starting from good photos and see your killer cost killers come with a
smile.
What's the line?
It's that.
It's that line.
Wherever that line is.
Ah,
any algae.
So anyways,
wait,
what did you learn about me?
You said you learn something about me.
Uh,
you shake your foot.
Oh,
I'm reason that this is what I've learned about you gel is that,
uh,
Joe is actually a big fan of romantic comedies.
I love him.
You don't like them?
Do you know why?
Because I,
they make me uncomfortable.
They make me not Joe,
with all your failed relationships.
I thought we lined up here with like hating that Sorta cheeseballs stuff.
Why are you fucking twitch in your foot?
What I do,
it's how I sit.
It's what I do when I sit.
What do you,
what do you care?
It's just,
it was fucking,
it's in my peripheral vision here.
It's like,
it's that distracting me.
Well,
it's my apartment.
Is that,
uh,
is,
is that,
no,
whatever that serviceness yeah,
it's nervousness.
You're,
you're a friend of the show here.
Opiate ethics.
I feel like a power either
compounds.
You trash me.
You think it's not going to happen.
Okay.
So,
but he just crossed his right foot back.
Oh,
I'm a nervous guy.
I shake my legs a lot.
Seriously.
I understand that.
And I want to,
I want to find out that I had that restless leg syndrome,
but that's not what that is.
That's when you're laying down.
Your legs won't stop moving.
I don't have that.
I'm like the 18 hundreds who has restless leg syndrome or they were just talking
about it recently.
Giant fucking fairy tale warts on your face,
living under a bridge.
So yeah,
I look,
here's why I like romantic comedies.
Hundred and 20,000 people died from restless leg syndrome.
He can't die from it.
You just,
you know,
Bill,
I think now you're taking the joke a little too,
but a fun personality just fits this fucking rain there.
You know?
You know what this asshole did.
This asshole.
This is what Joe,
just classic dirty white boy,
right?
It's fucking pouring out.
He fucking sits down.
He's putting on a brand new pair of sneakers.
They look great.
I'm like,
Joe,
what are you doing?
You're going to wear those outside?
He goes,
yeah,
you know,
I just,
I don't like new sneakers.
I got to muck them up a little bit.
Yeah,
I can look a little worn in.
That's all.
Why Joe?
So you can look like you know you're the real deal.
No,
they're just,
you're worried that people are gonna think that you're rich.
They are new.
They're nice.
They're not new.
But y'all,
when you buy it new from when you buy a new car,
someday you're going to sideswipe different muck it up a little bit.
Oh,
that's different.
See my beautiful wardrobe in there.
I keep my sport coats very crisp and clean.
I keep my ties iron.
Some things you like to look new.
Some things you like to look a little worn and it's like a buck when you get it.
What do you get when you get a baseball hat?
You don't want it to look brand new off the shelf.
Do you want it to have to the creases in the fucking face so that shit when they
walked down the street,
they can like smell you're sweaty hair now dude.
You like a brand new hat.
Have you ever seen when they,
they now sell the hats that look worn in for that very reason.
When I was in college,
I don't like those when I was in college.
What does the,
for those that are make it seem like you supported the team for years and
they're not.
They just look cooler.
That's it.
That's all it is.
That they're filthy.
They're not filthy.
They look worn in.
When I was in college,
guys would buy baseball hats.
We put them in the first,
he did put it in the Washer.
You'd wash it immediately to get it loose and,
and creased up a little bit cause it looked better.
Now then you take your brand new sneakers and run around in the rain because it
looked better.
Brandon,
who can make well they were new enough job,
nice shiny,
fucking lazy and they're not,
they're not getting that warning and look,
they still look puffy and like to like,
dude,
they look great.
All right to you.
My opinion doesn't mean you don't.
Good,
cool.
You look,
if he came out on on on a on stage with a nice new pair of sneakers and it's
been a coming out there with the fucking Mike Birbiglia wardrobe.
What are you talking about?
This is all frumpy.
That his book,
I don't,
you're stealing from Mike Birbiglia.
I'm not on stage.
I wear a tie.
I wear goddamn sweaters.
It look fucking fantastic when I'm on stage.
You know why Joe?
You say,
dude,
what ruins his suit?
Cheap shoes.
And You my friend,
we're cheap.
Youtube.
How do your mind,
no,
I'm not.
I'm totally competent.
You know what dress shoes cost.
That's not cut into it because that's tacky.
How much,
how much do they cost?
They cost enough.
My show,
they're almost see through.
I can watch you wiggle your toes.
You want me to go in there and pull out the dress shoes I'm wearing these days?
All these days.
Well they kicked it up a notch because the other days all meaning all the days I
ever worked with you,
you came out with some shit that meaning two years ago they look like you will
see.
I always will.
Years show is dressing your God Damn Hudson or uh,
whatever theater show you did hear town hall,
whatever.
Theater show,
town hall.
You mean the word?
Remember the name of it.
I'm saying like,
well nice to know was a big night and your life and it was a big night of my
life and I,
and I strolled in.
I looked like fucking sharp.
Everybody was going look at those fucking shoe.
They weren't,
they were talking about Liggett face cause you weren't all bloated with booze
for once.
They'll,
that's what we were talking about bill.
I had seven 15 fucking people come up to me that night and go,
dude,
those shoes or everybody who is listening right now,
you know when somebody's lying when they 17 people,
I counted them.
I tell quite say kick your butts in my shoes.
Okay fine,
my fault,
my fault.
But up until then Shell,
the shoe shoe wearing on stage looked like they were a combination of
fresh shows and dress shoes and slippers.
I know a pair of shoes you're talking about.
I wore them one time with you and you made fun of me and I never wore them again
because they didn't feel like hearing it from you and for your advice and that's
where you wore them on that in that whole tour.
Let's fight for your advice after that,
after that,
uh,
after that weekend I got emails from people going,
I thought your shoes were really nice.
I don't know why bill was fucking with your shoes so much on stage when you were
up there together.
Now the phantom emails of people who agreed with you and you're doing your day
with me.
I'm taking a note on it.
I'm not yelling.
I thought it was gonna be a funny conversation.
I didn't know.
You know Joe,
you're really,
your mood is really affected by the weather.
I'm really understand.
You know I,
I find,
I find myself to be quite presentable and I get a little offended when somebody
says that I that I looked like a bum.
I don't look like you look like a bum.
You said.
I said it was.
I said,
that's perfectly as look.
Yeah.
And I don't dress that way.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I dress very parents show you're a fucking fashion plate.
Thank you Jesus Christ.
All I told you to do is not wearing brand new sneakers in the fucking rain.
Just asked why you do it and muck them up a little bit and then you come in 10
minutes later,
pissed off how wet you got out there with your pants draped over the fucking
fan.
You want to wear a brand new sneakers out net salary.
Sorry for me giving a shit about your map brand new from the eighties time.
Then little,
they look brand new compared to the stuff that you usually wear.
Sorry Joe.
Well,
because Chuck's you're not supposed to wear to resent the fact that you say
that.
I'm not a nice dresser right now sitting around doing a podcast.
Well,
you know I am not,
but when I joined I look present.
I'm old school too.
I go on stage,
I look presentable,
dude.
I,
I wear fucking ties.
There were sport coats or sweaters or wear dress shoes.
I'm telling you something dude.
What that $120 a fucking
word that that gap suit that you wear gap.
You look like you're selling encyclopedias.
I didn't want to say that,
but when you go,
oh,
I didn't know that.
You're fucking with me.
Fucking,
you know,
this got all serious,
this is serious.
I know.
I just said you're baiting me of taking the bait.
Congratulations.
Yeah,
no,
it's the congratulations part.
Uh,
I'm say congratulations.
I'm glad you haven't fun.
I fell for it.
All right.
What do you weren't for me?
I always fall for it.
All right.
I don't,
I don't want the test.
So this is Joe to Rosa and I think,
uh,
every,
every once every six months we do an uninformed Joe,
tell our listeners why we're,
uh,
we're not doing an uninformed this week considering we're sitting here next to
each other because we're doing a movie.
We're shooting a movie,
uh,
that I am,
if I can say so.
Directing and producing and acting in and you are also acting in it and
producing it.
And it's a little crazy and busy right now.
So it's Robert Kelly,
Robert Kelly.
So we wrote a short film,
believe it or not,
us three shitheads actually are going to complete something.
Yes.
Incredible.
It is.
I was blown away last night when we're sitting here rehearsing and like,
this is actually fucking funny.
And we're actually going to ship this.
Yes.
And then what happens?
One rainy day,
a couple of comments about your wardrobe and all that fucking love and feeling.
I've been a little stressed with all the responsibilities I've,
uh,
to waken on.
It's so fucking loud.
Probably because you didn't check it before.
Now I'll be,
I have them on the same level.
Dude.
You have,
you have a fucking booming voice job.
It's here.
We can't be at the same level.
We were always at different levels when we do this.
Thanks Joe.
Thank you for basically stating what I said.
I kind of use your shit and say you always wanting to be nerves ready around on
12 o'clock.
That's exactly what it,
and that's how you sound in my head by the way.
You adjust the trim and I always tell you that you adjust the trim.
All right,
Joe,
you know something that people recommend movies.
All right,
here's something.
Here's somebody recommended this movie and I've never heard of it because it's a
romantic comedy.
Okay?
And I want to know what you think about and said,
uh,
movies.
Um,
some of the listeners will call me a fag,
but a watch the movie 500 days of summer.
It's by definition a romantic comedy.
But this one is really funny and pretty much for me sums up relationships in our
twenties and thirties.
I've heard it's a tremendous film.
I've never seen it.
What,
five,
500 days.
Why are there 500 days?
Because they're so in love that it,
the summer seems endow cause I think the girl's name is summer and the total
time that they're together as 500 days.
Ah,
I get it.
So 500 days.
So this person spends,
how much is 500 days?
About a year and a half.
Yeah.
So he sent 500 days with summer.
And what happens in the end?
God think he marries her and then it's the fall.
I don't think so.
I'm a,
I think it's a,
I think it's something where there's a little bit of a twist where one character
abortion doesn't believe in love and the other one does.
And then that sort of shifts,
you know what I mean?
Oh,
okay.
Is there an abortion or anything like that?
And I think there's a brutal rape scene.
It's fine.
I was going to see this hobby calc tells him jerking off in her face.
Yeah.
He comes in,
he shows his Dick.
That's right.
And that,
uh,
and he starts crying
that Harvey got with,
actually,
you want a great recommendation for a movie,
speaking of Harvey Cartel crying and jerking off that new bad lieutenant was
fucking amazing.
Nicolas Cage was off the charts in it.
I thought it was funny.
It was hilarious,
but it didn't,
it was that like a snakes on the plane thing where they'd started to make it
seriously.
Then they realize they actually had a comedy and they just went with it.
No,
it's supposed to be funny and creepy and it's both and it's fucking amazing.
Okay.
I think it was off to fucking meter in it meant all right.
He plays 500 days of summer is first.
I'm gonna check that out.
Just very brutal rape scene.
Do you know,
it's amazing.
Is just like,
you know,
every movie's been done that hasn't been done in a romantic comedy.
There's never been a brutal rape scene,
you know,
so it's funny is that that adjective with,
uh,
rape has been used so much that that's actually an expression,
brutal rape scene.
It's never a horrific rape scene.
You know what I mean?
Like whenever you look in,
uh,
like the movies and they review something,
they'll say a woefully miscast.
You're never horrifically miscast or another awful word,
another adjective that means an awful,
can you please help me do it?
I've just really talk myself.
Yeah,
I know what you mean.
It's always,
it's always brutal rape.
It's,
uh,
it's,
Carlos men see on that fuck you adjusted it.
Maybe I'm just cause it looks fine on the meter or your headphones turned away
when you start talking in my head.
You know what it sounds like.
You know,
like when a fucking black dudes back in the day had the hatchback and the stereo
from the bumper,
we're going to tell you what pill.
I hate to break it to you.
You're,
you're a little low as the problem.
What do you mean I'm a little low?
You're not going up.
Oh,
that's yours,
dude.
That's yours.
I turned you down.
I don't know when you're talking.
You're a little low.
I'm looking at the meter.
No,
I'm not.
I'm fine.
I'm right here,
dude.
I don't,
I don't want to get up in the red.
Okay.
Are you were you weren't a second ago.
That's the only reason I show.
It's called,
it's called dynamics.
Sometimes you bring him down,
you pull the listener's closer to their shop radios.
All right.
What happened?
Talk Radios.
Oh,
I got you a clock radio,
by the way.
I know you gave it to me already.
Thank you.
Yeah,
the old fashioned one.
Just thank you Juan with batteries.
Thank you.
In the shower.
I said thank you very much.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
All right,
let's do it anyways.
When making a fucking movie making a fucking movie,
I feel like it's like citizen Kane.
I'm going to do a big speech tomorrow before we shoot the first thing.
What do you think my speech should be?
No.
Everybody's thinking.
What is it about?
It's a romantic comedy and believe it or not,
there's a brutal rape
and we're going to get Harvey cartel to come down and show his cock and it's
going to be the greatest.
Uh,
how long has this film?
About 20 minutes.
Yeah.
I mean hopefully it will be down the 15 when we're all done with it,
but we can't tell you what it's about.
You're just going to have to wait for it to come to your local AMC 20 minute
movies theaters.
Yeah.
Look for it on Netflix on some sort of best of short films of 2010 or maybe they
can show it,
uh,
maybe they can show it.
Uh,
you know,
in the beginning when they tried to get you to buy popcorn and that type of
shit.
Well,
what I was thinking is we can maybe shop it around to some theaters like some of
these art house theaters and see if they'll show it before the features.
I think some theaters do that sort of thing near bill.
And the last thing you want to do is put it up on the Internet.
So all these clients get it for free and we just have more free up.
But you have to do it now.
Isn't that what it is?
Yeah,
you have to.
I have to.
Who the fuck are you to charge people?
What do you get after we invested all this money in the movie and I like when
people send you emails and letters.
Yeah,
I downloaded you held him.
Sorry Dude.
Lol.
Like you think it's funny.
You know what I mean?
It's like it's not funny.
It isn't.
You can't,
you're cheap fox.
Yeah.
Af.
Whenever it happened I do that.
So next week everyone's going to send me emails telling me that they illegally
downloaded my shit,
thinking that they're totally original,
that they sent me the newer,
there's a band called spoon.
I'm a big fan of them.
Their new album just came out and the last thing it says in the liner notes is a
buying,
buying records in record stores is cool.
Like,
you know,
I don't know why everybody has turned their back on this,
but it's still awesome to go in and actually buy an album and read the liner
notes and look at the hard work and all that shit.
So I gotta be honest.
If I was young and I had no money and I never paid for music,
like think of something you never paid,
but what they were able to do that with water.
I never paid for water when I was a kid.
Oh,
I know.
We have to scare them.
That free music is actually going to give you cancer or something like that.
They tried like they did with the water.
They try it.
They said,
they said you're going to get viruses and all and everybody downloading files
was going to get caught.
And then what happened?
Fucking hipster Mack came along and apple said,
uh,
hey guys,
you don't get viruses with our computers.
Have a fucking field day.
Viruses on this thing is cause the,
uh,
the virus makers haven't decided to attack it.
Isn't that why?
I don't understand why because everybody likes the underdog.
But eventually these,
these guys aren't going to be the underdog,
the apples,
and then,
and then when they catch up with pcs,
you don't,
it's like,
it's like the Red Sox,
you know,
if it was red sox,
Yankees and the red sox hadn't won in so long,
a lot of people,
you know,
ah,
go with the fucking red sox just cause they're the underdogs.
And then once we won and then we were walking around,
go fucking champions man.
Everybody immediately fucking hated us.
And now I would say arguably we are,
uh,
just about as hated as the Yankees,
I would think,
oh wait,
I'm talking sports,
dub tuned out sports.
I'll talk sports.
This is how much I don't give a shit about sports.
You were talking about that and you see that empty plastic container over there.
I literally zoned in on that and just was focused on that 100% we know some
Joel,
I don't like romantic comedies either,
but when you talk about them,
I at least have the decency to listen to her.
Did you though the underdogs I got with you.
You heard that?
A couple of nouns.
I'm with Ya.
I'm breaking your balls back.
A little fucking fresh roommate fresh with me.
All right,
Joey,
we got something here.
A another,
a segment on my podcast.
We've got segments on this podcast.
Julia.
Bill.
Yes I do.
You would like to hear another one?
Yes.
Should I want called?
Unacceptable.
All right.
This is the one I learned.
That's the word I use now instead of you fucking cunt.
When I'm,
when I'm mad at corporations,
I keep my cool.
I try to,
unless I get,
I forget myself at halftime speech before I call up and I just,
I just keep telling them whatever is going on is unacceptable.
Yeah.
Well they,
I,
there's no one above me.
Uh,
you can't talk to him.
That's unacceptable.
I have to talk to someone above,
you know,
you're not running the company.
I know you just doing your job,
man.
You do the nice thing.
He just keeps saying it's unacceptable.
So here's an unacceptable one that has to do with Kentucky Fried Chicken.
All right.
Let me see if I can get to the state of Kentucky Fried Chicken.
I know.
That's why I decided to read this.
I'm like,
Joe likes to eat that slop.
Stylish.
You're that Christmas song.
Uh Huh.
Did you hear it know?
It was ridiculous.
It sounded like a Saturday night.
Live sketch is ridiculous.
He's literally did songs like here comes Santa Claus and it's Bob Dylan going,
it goes there to close here.
Hosanna.
Close Down Santa.
It was re dickless rolling stone gave it.
I didn't,
I don't know.
Did they say he?
He redefined Christmas.
He probably,
I am not a fan of Bob Dylan's work.
I appreciate the man's abilities and his skill and his talent.
I do not ever want to listen to any of his music ever like that.
Tangled up in blue.
He's got a couple songs that how's that want to go?
He does him and his either day,
but he gave it to Dubai blue.
Where did the day of his [inaudible] hair.
But today with the dealer,
I like Lay lady lay lay across my big brass band.
Oh,
I hate that one.
I like that word.
Hey,
can you guys vote out there and just say,
well,
which one of us is more tone deaf when we sing
the,
uh,
yeah,
I like that.
I want,
I like a hurricane.
I know that's a cheesy when the lake,
but I like it.
Yeah.
That's the one they end up making the movie with Denzel and everybody flipped
out because Denzel didn't win a uh,
an Oscar,
which obviously meant that it was racist.
Right?
Forget about the fact that Martin Scorsese,
fucking
good fellows,
raging bull and like fucking whatever,
taxi driver,
all these other,
and he never won one,
but it's racism because he gets it because he got passed over.
Well,
the fair point they make is no black guys ever win them.
I agree with that.
I agree that they would go for Christ shakes.
Denzel is the guy that's made it to the top.
You know what?
You need to give the guy in act and ask her.
It's not like you're giving it to tons of black dudes.
I think it was him and shitty poured yet.
That's kind of like that.
That's,
but that is in a way
not necessarily racist and I got to wait till everybody goes,
oh geeze,
is flipping out.
Because still,
you know what is people,
you know what I've learned to stand up is people give a fuck about themselves
and not in a bad necessarily,
always 100% in a bad way.
People are focused on themselves and what appeals to them in their fucking
group.
So they're not going to be like the fact that a bunch of white people continue
watch white movies and go,
oh my,
it made me cry.
I totally could relate is not racist.
Right.
It's like when like,
okay,
I did,
I was talking about this last week.
I'm doing standup,
right?
I'm telling jokes said,
show.
I'm out there.
I'm,
I'm killing the room.
Alright.
I come out.
One of the first things I did,
I was talking about swine flu and the gist of the joke is I'm wishing a plague
on the world.
Everybody's laughing,
everybody's having a great time.
Then I came around to that bid.
What do you have fig making fun of Homophobia.
But there was I guess a,
at least one gay dude or someone who had a gay brother.
I don't know if there was four of them.
And I guess in the middle of it someone went fucking homophobe.
But I couldn't hear what he was saying because of a,
you know,
I don't know.
My ears are fucked up.
I couldn't hear it.
So I said,
what'd you say?
And I guess they stormed out.
And I found out later that he said,
you fucking homophobe.
First of all,
the joke was making fun of Homophobia.
And not only that too,
I made fun of fat people.
I wish plagues and everybody and everything was fucking fine.
Everything was funny.
Everything is a fucking joke until it comes around to that shit because that's
what the fuck that do give a fuck about because that's his daily existence being
that guy.
So what I'm saying,
it's just because a bunch of white people,
k a forties and 50s alright,
you got us sixties you got us,
but seventies eighties nineties and all the way through.
If a bunch of white people are paying attention to white movies,
you know,
I know what you mean man.
I know what you mean.
People just,
you know,
I got grown up the other night at Piss me off because I was talking about
America help in Haiti out and I was like,
you know,
you don't understand.
You tell you,
you're telling me we need to stay out of Iraq but we need to go into Haiti.
And I was like,
don't you see how one can't happen without the other?
We have to steal the oil so we can be the super power so we can help Haiti.
Then you know,
it's great.
It's already talking about putting a permanent base down there so we can protect
them,
build our empire.
Let me,
let,
let us help us out.
I'm going to do is build a best buy.
So I go,
don't you get it?
I go,
I go where the,
where the celebrity,
like this is how celebrities work.
We're,
we're like Angelina Jolie,
like she probably,
you know,
fucking threw coffee in some intern space once I'm burn the skin off his skull
and she's like,
I feel shitty about that.
Let me go adopt a black kid and just bring it all full circle and I go adopt a
black kid.
Everybody goes,
oh.
And it's like,
what?
What do you groaning at it?
Right.
I'll tell you what,
they're grown in that because they want to believe Joe.
People want to believe that people are good and that they do things because for
good reasons only.
But if I would've said poor kid,
they wouldn't have grown.
I should black kids.
So they groaned.
It was a black kid was at that and not only was it a black kid who was the best
looking black kid she could find over there.
I know they get that little blue fucking Mohawk.
Yeah,
she gets,
she got the American idol,
a black kid.
Shit,
I can't take this.
I got Lou.
She keep that she could get pick up the phone,
Huh?
Yes.
Let it ring.
You.
Don't give a fuck.
The fact that I was adjusting the levels as we were doing the shelf that didn't
give it away,
that this thing was kind of fly by night.
All right,
so yeah,
you,
you made it,
you made a point.
But that's the thing like you have to learn to,
if you are the group that is kind of running shit,
you,
you do have to have some empathy and you do have to let every once in a while
you got to toss somebody in Oscar.
I get,
is that my point?
I'm just saying,
I mean,
do you think like the,
all those Arab cab drivers give a fuck that they,
that they pushed out a,
you know,
fucking patty make overwork or whatever.
He doesn't get to drive a fucking cab anymore.
What about all these Irish guys?
Hey,
hey Mac way you're going,
those guys all get kicked out and you think they give a fuck.
They don't,
but do they,
does that mean they hate Irish people?
They don't give a shit that just fucking hooking each other up.
You're gonna feel bad for it.
They like each other and I feel bad for Indians.
Did I just compare black people not getting an Oscar do an Irish guy not being
able to drive a cab that fucking moron.
But I feel bad for Indians,
not American Indians.
I mean,
I feel bad for them too.
But India Indians that real because they had,
they had the seven 11 industry locked down.
That was their shit.
And now it's all Arab dudes and I'm Arab.
So good for good for the Arabs.
But they just got shoved out of that businessman habitat that they got shoved.
They also had the whole world locked down at one point and then England went
over there and took them over.
Yeah.
That's kind of what happened to them a lot.
We all,
man,
they England take anything over.
I like him to England,
but you know,
I dunno Joe.
I've read switching and I bullied by an English kid.
I read like a third of a book that about Winston Churchill and Gandhi.
And then I,
uh,
I don't know what I did after that.
I started reading this book about Rick Flare after that.
All right.
I love what ric flair he wanted me to.
Let me,
let's get back to the,
uh,
unacceptable story here.
Um,
we just sound so fucking stupid dude.
Oh,
by the way,
and this is this,
this is why we do the radio show.
Uninformed.
Absolutely.
I,
you know,
and you know what's great about is the fucking people who listen to this,
it makes them feel better about themselves.
Like they're not fucking morons too.
That's my fear.
That's my favorite part of this shelf.
These guys are folk and ut.
I said,
I felt sorry for aiding the Indians.
There you go.
They ruled the world.
So the English took over.
Then I said,
how do you let it English guy who push you around?
And then you said,
so that about Rick flare,
it was just
stream of stupidity.
There was not one worthwhile,
my fantasy,
Joe,
that I'm actually,
that my listeners are just as dumb as I am.
I hope so.
I just throw it out there because I don't have to have,
one of the great thing Joe,
about free art is you don't have to be nice to the people who listened to me
because I've had people complain and I've just been like,
hey,
look,
y'all don't listen.
You don't mind fantasy.
Am I going to make,
how do you make less than zero?
I guess you can make you can lose money.
My fantasy is that the people that listened to the uninformed show are actually
smarter than us and cultured and build us up.
Like it's,
it's a brilliant commentary on the thought process of the average American and
we,
it's that what they actually think that we're smart and the genuine article,
it's like one of those movies where the,
you know,
where the guy doesn't know what the fuck he's doing becomes famous because of
it.
They're just like,
yeah,
sure.
Everybody,
I'll play along.
Then there's a brutal
rape scene.
All right.
His Unacceptable
Kentucky Fried Chicken.
Here we go.
Uh,
would've fucked.
Did we start anyways?
I want to share with you my unexpect unacceptable experience at KFC.
Uh,
there is a KFC by my house that,
uh,
at least three quarters of the time I visited does not have any crispy chicken
available.
And last night when I went there at six fucking 30 pm right in the middle of the
dinner hour,
now my computer just shit,
I'm right in the middle of the dinner hour,
they again told me,
sorry,
no crispy chicken at this time it will take 16 minutes to cook more.
Um,
I had enough,
did not respond in any ways that the pumps,
pumps,
could not turn anything around on me.
And I just left,
went down to a,
I don't know if you've got a chili dog or some shit.
Anyways,
so today after work I found myself craving crispy chicken breasts and a wing
combol again and against my better judgment,
I went back to this fucking place.
They gave me my meal and I started to leave.
But before I left I was like,
you know what?
These people don't exactly have a great track record.
So I opened the bag and Lo and behold,
the breast lift,
the little small,
I lifted the skin.
So it was dark meats.
So I went back to the drive through window and waited five minutes while blowing
my horn for someone to at least give a shit.
When the girl came to window,
I said very nicely.
I asked her breasts and a wing and I got a thigh.
She said to me,
now,
I made it my thought,
it's a breath.
Uh,
like I'm too retarded to know the difference between white and dark meat and the
sizes as well.
So I said,
no,
I eat breasts a lot.
I know what a breast is.
She began to spew some crap about,
it was just some sort of small breast or something.
Uh,
but because I didn't let her finish,
I just said it's a thigh.
So finally she decided to realize I wasn't taking any crap.
So she said,
okay,
five minutes later they bring my food back asking me if I need any sauces,
like nor they're too little,
too late.
Attempt to customer service,
took the food and left.
When I got home,
they hadn't closed the mashed potatoes.
All the gravy was spilled all over the side of the box.
Not only that,
but the breast they gave me was only partially cooks.
Obviously,
once again,
they were ill prepared,
blah,
blah.
Um,
so for the first time in my life,
I find myself writing a letter of complaint to the company's corporation
headquarters in which I described the situation above with the word
unacceptable,
intermittently dispersed throughout the letter.
Not sure how long it will be before I receive any responses,
but their website feedback only allowed 1800 cares.
This is where it goes off the rails because he hasn't found out what happened.
Well,
this is your problem.
Number one,
why don't don't run.
First of all,
you did the right thing by,
by making an account of all the mishaps.
Don't write a letter,
just call the play shop called the customer service line on the website.
Complain and demand compensation before you hang up.
And they'll probably send you a bunch of free coupons and shit like that so he
can go back to this completely inept KFC.
The thing about this is raised,
you know free.
Fuck it.
You know
some serious you.
Please say that again,
Joe.
It's free.
Fuck it here.
There you go.
Okay,
well,
Jonathan Rosen,
this is what I brought Joe in.
Every once in a while I bring an expert in just like Oprah.
You should be sitting here in scrubs right now.
Dude,
I know some,
I got admit when it comes to food,
I don't really,
I don't complain.
Like I,
I would ask them my money back and I would go that route,
but I would not be like,
you know,
listen,
you know it's a thigh.
I know what a thigh is.
Get me a thigh and then they disappear and come back.
I mean,
I'll tell you what he needs to do because that,
dude,
I've done this show many times.
I've been in these situations that I always complained.
I would go to the manager of the restaurant,
right and go and be like,
I don't mean the night shift manager.
I want the guy that runs this shop,
that guy,
he's not here Wednesday.
Here,
I'll be back and go back.
And then you go to that guy and you go,
listen to me buddy.
Here's all the shit you guys fucked up.
Don't curse.
But you know,
however you got to say,
yeah,
no,
I like this fantasy calm Joe that you're creating.
No,
trust me,
I did.
This is what I would,
you've actually been able to,
when I have to do this,
yeah.
If I collect myself,
I can do this.
If I call in the moment,
that's when I fuck up,
but if I,
if I get my shit together,
I can do this.
You go and calm and you go,
listen,
here's the deal.
These are all the mistakes you've made.
I'm a loyal customer.
I spend a lot of money here.
I keep coming back.
I'm telling you right now,
either you give me compensation and you really got to play up.
This is the angle you got to play up.
You can't just say,
I ordered this and I got that because then it's just going to be like,
well,
they made a mistake.
You got to play up.
Every time I order,
they gave me the wrong thing,
but what's worse than that and what's truly unacceptable?
People make mistakes.
Okay,
fine.
Get to the point Gel.
The fact that your staff,
the fact that your staff is unable to live up to their mistakes.
And when I asked for them to rectify them,
they give me an attitude like I am somehow wrong for the,
for what they,
what they screwed up.
Oh you know what?
You're 100% right cause I'm about ready to give you a refund just to not listen
to the rest of it.
Then you go and you go work with me here and with the guy gives you any problem.
Then you go,
well I'm going to go to corporate.
I want your store number and I want your full name Jesus and try and go and go.
And if the guy gives you any trouble,
go really,
you're not going to give it to me.
Why know your first name?
Because they've seen your name tag.
You think I'm not going to figure out what this is because some of them won't do
that.
Like I've had people walk away from it.
I'm not giving you information.
Threatened a man showed Rosa says to make threats.
I liked that.
But after,
I'll call it corporate.
Alright,
here's overrated unrated.
We got to start wrapping this thing up here.
Jump seats.
I got to actually,
I've got to go now.
Actually.
I got trust.
Thank you for rod dropping in and dropping by.
I got to go into the other room.
Help your cancer dry on the fan.
I fucking missed this place man.
Thanks a lot.
All right.
Chuck something?
Yeah.
Why not show or your cell phone.
Thanks bill.
By a whore out your sneaker contract.
My album is coming out on comedy central records.
It will be out very soon.
Uh,
what,
what'd you
call it?
Did you call it?
What I wanted you to call it.
No,
I call,
it's called the depression auction,
which I think is a great title.
Uh,
so why are you shaking your head?
You don't like it?
I liked your other one better.
It's fuck time at the ship.
Party dickhead.
Yeah.
They won't let me name it that cause to me curses and the title.
Ah,
did that and that promotes curiosity.
Is this,
the next one would have been the look on your face.
Like something was about ready to happen.
It looks like it'd be [inaudible] Shit Party dickhead.
Elegant.
Great.
Um,
anyway,
it's called the depression auction will be on comedy central records and a
couple of months and uh,
I got some headlining dates coming up.
I'm doing Jesus.
Joe,
you've got a night at winii brand stress factory in February I think.
Is that like Tyler Perry's stress factory?
Vinnie brands?
Yeah.
Stress Factor.
Yeah,
New Brunswick,
New Jersey.
It's on Thursday,
I believe.
The 11th I think she'll come out to that.
All right.
Yeah,
that was some of the worst typing average Jonah rose,
everybody,
I swear to God,
you know,
he's what happened?
You just lost your ra,
your momentum there.
No,
I was trying to,
because I thought I wanted you to be happy when my album title and you kind of
shook your head and I,
you know,
he might not,
I like it.
But I'm just saying like,
I this shit.
Tell him what the fuck party I was kind of wishing you know,
fuck time.
It's a shift.
Whatever the fuck it is.
It's funny.
I know.
I just,
it was like it couldn't happen.
I had to call it something out.
And Depression auction is a bit I do and it says they won't let you,
which is why we're making our own fucking movie.
Exactly.
Cause that's what this business is.
You come up with an idea and then you go up to these people who aren't funny and
you go,
is it okay if we do this?
And they're like,
no,
it isn't.
And you go,
okay,
and you've got to come back with some other stuff.
I actually never even asked.
Very cool.
I'm disappointing.
And you like a parent.
All right.
Okay.
So now it's back to the regular podcast.
Me Just babbling.
I'm marine underrated.
Overrated.
Um,
over the week,
here's a question.
Do I,
have,
I asked you guys,
what do you think is more a overpriced,
okay.
Just little cunty fucking items.
When he thinks more overpriced disposable razors or orange juice cause both of
those products they've somehow,
like if I was in the corporate world and I was trying to decide how to make more
money off of our product,
that would be my,
my presentation that we somehow have to have our product to be perceived the
same way.
Disposable razors in orange juice,
orange juice.
I always say that we're on orange,
orange juice are perceived and that would be my presentation.
I have like this fucking buildup of music and I would be like,
it would be like disposable razors,
orange juice,
and then Bam,
whatever the fuck we was selling,
you know,
fucking Koolaid,
just like orange juice.
It is,
it is drank and it's a different color than water.
All right,
now I know why I'm a comic and I'm not in the corporate world.
let's get to overrate.
Underrated.
Overrated.
I'm drinking under the age of 21 I've always been a good kid.
Good kid,
quote unquote.
What does that,
that meant you didn't drink but you,
you fucking vandalized places and never started drinking.
Even now that I'm 19.
Ah,
however,
all the guys I knew who had been getting wasted since 14 are,
are all huge losers.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
Isn't that true if you start at 17 year,
okay.
That's what I'm advocating under age drinking from 17 on a yeah.
Those people who if you start drinking at 14,
you have a terrible home life or you're just a,
you're a,
you're a follower and a,
yeah.
All those kids,
that's basically a,
the,
yeah.
The kids had started drinking in eighth grade.
If you can't make it to fucking out of junior high,
if you can't make it to high school without needing a fucking scotch to take the
edge off from,
you know,
adding and subtracting fractions,
you're just on your way to the gutter.
Um,
anyways,
he said,
I still have fun and I still meet girls.
Uh,
by the way,
I don't think booze is a bad,
is bad or anything.
I do plan on getting hammered on my 21st birthday,
which is actually on Saint Patrick's Day,
but it's not essential to having fun.
Like most people think.
Um,
you know something,
I'm not trying to fuck up what you're doing here because I think what you're
doing here is great,
but,
um,
until you've gone out and get in,
gotten shit face,
you really don't know which is better.
Okay.
But it's great that you have it because what you haven't done is you haven't
opened up Pandora's box.
It's Kinda like me,
you know,
sitting here going,
you know what?
I don't need heroin.
You know,
I feel great.
if I go to the gym,
I feel fucking awesome.
You know?
That's all I need.
You know,
why?
Because I've never felt how awesome heroin feels.
Does that make any sense?
This is a really a fucking irresponsible thing that I'm doing here.
I'm almost like encouraging you to go drink.
I'm just saying,
you know what,
I,
you know,
if you don't drink until then,
you might not want it.
You just never fucking do it.
It's not good for you.
Dries out your joints,
you drink enough of it.
You need like a fucking hip replacement.
I actually,
I think that's more like if you do like cocaine,
crystal meth.
I,
yeah.
Why do,
why do I even try?
I don't even have to fuck.
I'm talking writer,
underrated girls who wink at you.
I was introduced to a girl by my friend last night.
She winked at me and I almost creamed right there.
Ah,
dude.
You know what?
I'm jealousy.
You,
you are a,
you ever hear that thing how you can't,
you can't go back.
He can never go back.
He can't recapture your innocence.
Like I just wish I could somehow,
um,
you know,
like when you get an external hard drive and you take all this shit off your
laptop and then you just drag it into the hard drive so you're fucking laptop
runs smoothly again.
I wish I could do that with my brain and I,
and the first thing I would do is I would take all the porn that I ever watched
and I would just eliminate that,
you know?
And I would just put that on the fucking,
uh,
you know,
I bet we're about five years away from being able to do that shit.
That would be great.
I do that.
MMM.
Couple of chicks,
the memory of a couple of checks I fucked up in life.
Fuck it.
Download that.
Put that shit there.
MMM.
What other dumb shit?
What else has been fucking me up?
Okay.
Oh,
whatever.
I don't fucking know.
I wish I could do that Shit
for girl winked at me now I'd be like,
Oh God,
what a fucking cheese ball.
Yeah,
but she can't kiss who fucking winks.
I said,
I would think,
but if I was your age and I hadn't drank yet,
some fucking,
uh,
winked at me.
Yeah.
I would have fucking,
that would have been it.
That would've been it.
Um,
that was really depressing.
What I just fucking said.
I think more so for me to do,
you know what?
You're doing the right thing.
You live in life the right way,
Dona.
Yeah,
don't do it.
Don't do it.
Don't do whatever everybody else does.
Okay.
You go out,
you get shit faced.
And then you move on to fucking weed and then you fucking bang as many fucking
chicks as she can and you think that you're accumulating all this shit and all
you're doing is taking a hammer and a chisel to your fucking soul,
and you're just moving further and further away from fucking do you know?
I think true happiness is,
it's,
it's being,
uh,
I dunno,
not ignorant.
Just fucking,
yeah,
you didn't,
you didn't indulge.
I just,
I don't know.
Um,
uh,
you know what?
I'm glad Joe was here.
I didn't realize I was just fucking depressed this week.
Yeah.
It's just all the bullshit.
You know what I mean?
It's like if she takes a minute to fucking eat a donut,
right?
But it takes you an hour to burn it off.
You know that all that fucking Goddamn treadmill is just said,
am I really giving you guys a whiny?
It isn't fair speech,
Joe.
This whole fucking thing just went off the,
uh,
off the rails.
What happens when I leave?
Is that what happens?
Do you need me around?
Well,
why don't you help me wrap this up.
I gotta get my rides downstairs.
You'll ride.
This is New York City equipment for the big film though.
Okay.
Jesus show you can,
you know what my odds of somebody snapping on set tomorrow.
Oh,
you're a,
I'm guessing,
you know,
that was me.
I'm just trying to be funny.
I wasn't standing up,
but there's a tension in your voice.
I was gone.
We got to pick up the equipment there,
Phil.
Oh,
try to be funny.
All right.
Your face is a little tight.
I'll always is bill
Sanders?
Not a general.
Okay.
This,
this podcast.
It's just been an absolute cluster fuck.
But you know something,
I dragged a mixer across the goddamn country.
Few people.
All right.
And um,
I want the first of all,
you know,
I know I kind of Shit on you guys this week calling you morons in that type of
thing.
And uh,
if you don't have listen to this again,
I'd fucking understand.
And uh,
you know,
I'll learn my lesson and I'll come back on next week under a disguise.
Name is someone else.
I think I found a new place where I'm going to be,
uh,
doing these podcasts.
I have time to do one more podcast on g cast.
Uh,
I'll do it next Sunday for when I'm in Tampa.
I will be in Tampa,
Florida and a at the Improv.
So please come out.
And,
uh,
all the last thing too,
by the way,
that theater I'm playing in England I guess is the Lester Theater for some
reason.
It's,
it's,
I don't even know.
It's pretty,
it's fucking written like l e.
R maybe that's like some of their history.
You know,
Europeans always talking about America,
how there was no history over here,
you know what I mean?
No documented history,
I mean,
I'm sorry we didn't build some fucking castles that you guys don't even want to
visit unless you're in the fifth grade.
They make you take a fucking field trip over there and do a report on it.
But anyways,
I'll be over there.
Um,
the Lester Theater in London,
England on the 18th and the 19th.
I'm in Dublin,
Ireland,
I believe at the sugar club.
And then I'm at Glasgow.
I thought it was glass Gal,
but it's Glasgow,
g o w uh,
I guess it's said like slow Glasgow,
Scotland.
And it was a couple of places like that,
like,
um,
Oregon people read it and they,
and that's a big thing that people in the state of Oregon,
Joe's walking out there like it's not Oregon.
It's Oregon.
Really.
Then why don't you spell it?
Gin.
Wow.
I'm actually doing bits now about the dual wacky names of states.
I'm going to fucking end this.
I don't know what happened.
Anyways,
I'm frazzled.
We're shooting a movie this week.
I'll let you guys know when that thing comes out and uh,
where you can purchase it and then one of you will purchase it and then you'll
put it up on youtube and then everybody will take it for free.
Lol.
Oh my God.
Laughing my ass off.
Oh,
by the way,
I actually,
uh,
got it.
That fucking band laughing my fucking ass off.
L M a o F as that.
ESL laughing my LM.
I don't fucking know.
Whatever work it out.
Um,
have you heard that song that they do that shot's song?
I'm sure you've heard of those guys.
When I first heard that song,
I'm in Miami Bitch.
I thought that they were idiots and that,
that that was the end of music and now I realize the fucking genius of what
those guys are doing.
If I was fucking 1920 2122 in that fucking song came on in a bar in a club,
people must be just going absolutely out of their fucking minds when that comes
on.
And then did the fucking hot bartenders jump up like our net,
that fucking coyote ugly and they start pouring shots.
If I was a club owner right now,
that's the fucking song I would be playing.
And I pour out shots to all you youngsters and then I would hire a couple of
more illegal aliens with mops and buckets to wipe up all your puke.
You inexperienced vox.
But that's a great fucking,
that's a great God damn song that actually made me want to go out and drink.
But I haven't,
if you're wondering,
I still haven't drank.
What in the fuck is today is the 25th.
So I'm 24 fucking days in.
And uh,
this is my Catholic school upbringing.
I'm on punishment right now.
I sinned on January 1st and I just want Jesus to forgive me.
Um,
that's it.
That's it for the podcast.
I know it was all over the place.
I know it's sucked and uh,
so you know,
I already know.
Oh fuck.
I forgot to tell us story.
This one's going to be long.
All right.
Real quick.
I went to a lot of the Ucla,
Ucla Bruins for uh,
at uh,
the poly pavilion.
This'll be funny.
This is worse hanging out for all right.
And I was sitting down and I was down in the front row right behind the basket
and it,
because it's college sports,
you know,
you can get that for like fucking 65 bucks,
you know.
So we show up,
meet a buddy of mine and there's this guy in the,
in the,
in a blue UCLA blue,
like Afro Wig saw my guy,
right?
He's the crazy guy.
And right off the bat that was just something off about the guy and I couldn't
figure out what he started clapping and rocking back and forth.
And I just thought it was the typical white dude with no rhythm.
And uh,
it just got progressively,
it first it was funny and then you realize that the guy was mildly,
uh,
what is the politically correct term for a target?
Mildly mentally challenged.
And uh,
every once in a while a cheerleader,
a male cheerleader,
would come by.
By the way,
what's worse,
a male stewardess or cheerleader,
if you were a father,
which one would you be more disappointed?
Um,
male cheerleader comes by and he goes,
all right,
we're going to do an eight clap.
And I guess they got this chair and they just go,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight.
You see,
Eh,
like you see la fight,
fight,
fight.
That's like that,
that fucking Shit,
right?
So he comes out and he brings this sign and he goes,
all right everybody,
we're going to do an eight count.
And this fucking dude who's like literally almost 50 years old and he has this
really high pitched voice with the Blue Afro.
He just gets up.
He goes,
I know.
And I know and I know and I know it starts doing the chair with the male
cheerleader and uh,
what is the word for that?
That laugh,
that auto political correctness.
You're not laughing because the person is uh,
you know,
got some issues.
You know,
they have a,
for the grace of God go,
I,
but what he's doing is fucking hilarious.
Like when the other team would go to take a foul shot,
you know,
people,
if they yell and they scream,
he would get up and he would that we would like 10 feet behind the bucket like
that.
And that whole area was wide open for the cheerleaders.
He would walk up there and just be like jumping up and down like an absolute
fucking spectacle.
And I swear to God,
he was actually,
he was so fucked up,
he was actually making people miss their shots.
Well cause this old lady was like really annoyed because she had season tickets.
She's like,
he comes here every game,
he's here every game and he thinks he takes credit when they miss.
And I wasn't,
you know,
I respect old people too.
And I also don't like making fun of people who are mentally,
uh,
you know,
challenged.
But,
you know,
it was,
it was a fucking situation there,
right.
I'm trying not to fucking laugh,
but the guy was hilarious and he was literally making people miss their shots.
And,
uh,
you know what the fun of the whole thing was was when he would walk up to people
that they,
that you know,
didn't know him.
It just watching them,
the look on their faces as they slowly figured it out.
Like they're like,
well,
what's with this guy?
Is he drunk?
Oh,
oh,
okay.
And then they would sort of look down and some people would engage and they
would shake his hand and be like,
hello.
But then it was,
became this conversation that you couldn't get out of a,
but I have to admit to one of my ears is fucked up.
And his,
his voice was so fucking loud.
Um,
I think he actually furthered my fucking tinnitus.
So if you go to a UCLA game and,
uh,
even if they lose,
um,
you,
you're going to get a fucking show because that dude is,
he's absolutely hilarious.
I think his name is Steve.
I don't know why I'm not making fun of the fucking guy.
I guess I kind of was,
but I don't know.
I should,
I should have tapped out like 10 minutes ago.
I probably shouldn't have told that fucking story cause I actually had a good
time.
Legendary or Nina
just talking to my son at this point.
Sure.